[Music]
what's up guys mkbhd here and one of my
favorite things about making videos with
this high-end gear
is the images that these cameras can
capture is legit absolutely incredible
behind the scenes what you might not
know is the actual video file that i'm
uploading to youtube looks
significantly better on my computer
than on youtube like it looks pretty
good on youtube and you can watch in 4k
and it looks pretty crispy and sharp and
but it looks
miles better when i'm looking at it in
quicktime on my computer after i've
exported it to the point where sometimes
i'm like
why do i spend so much time on like the
little things just little color
adjustments little tiny
sharpening and stabilization and things
like that when at the end of the day
you're just going to watch it on your
phone or on some laptop and not really
notice 99 of that stuff and it's of
course because that process is so fun
but it's also become kind of a running
joke that like if you want to shoot at a
crazy high iso or if you have a ton of
noise you don't really need a denoiser
because youtube processing will just
clean up all that noise for you it'll
just soften it up anyway all this is
because
youtube has to compress the file we
upload so in order to process all the
millions of hours of video being
uploaded to the site every month and
process them into a 4k version and a
1440p version a 1080 a 720 a 480 all
these versions and dynamically switch
between them all they've got to do some
smart streamlining and part of that is
crunching down the video files to as
small as they reasonably can so if i
upload this video for example this
beautiful crispy
probably five gigabyte or so final file
when it's all done and rendered out
youtube isn't turning around and playing
back that five gigabyte monstrous file
to you your internet's not good enough
to do that in the first place what
they've correctly assumed is that they
can compress it all the way down to just
a few megabytes
and it'll look pretty much just as good
and it'll speed things up significantly
so that being said
i've always been
curious
how serious is this compression how
serious
is youtube processing
in 2019
and turns out sort of the best way to
test that would be to upload a video
and then download that video and then
check out the difference but of course
one time's not enough you got to do it i
guess mr b style basically at this point
so the plan is upload a video to youtube
let it process
then download that video
then upload that video let it process
download that one upload that download
it again and keep going
and keep going and keep going until it
breaks further and further down
and we'll do that
a thousand times so this idea this has
actually been done before backed by a
channel in 2010 about a decade ago
called ontologist and they did this with
a webcam video but i suspect with
changes in scale and different codecs
youtube's processing has evolved a bit
since then um plus they now support hd
videos so here we are at the end of 2019
let's see if youtube's processing
has gotten any better
or any worse let's see how good it
really is in 2019.
all right so i'm sitting in a room
different from the one you're in right
now and i'm recording both the sound of
my voice
and an image of myself
and i'm going to upload it to youtube
rip it from youtube
and then upload it again and download
and upload again and again and again
until all the original characteristics
of my voice
and my image
are destroyed
this is a test of youtube processing
in 2019
okay so this is the original file it's
8k it's super sharp super clean
white background and you know to me
moving around a little bit uh high
quality audio as well so this is sort of
your classic
talking head tech video
this is our base
our starting point
all right so i'm sitting in a room
different from the one you're in right
now and i'm recording both the sound of
my voice
and an image of myself so this is file
number two so this is downloaded from
youtube's native downloader so in the
youtube video manager they give you a
download option
and this gives us back a 720p version so
it's going to be 720p from here on out
which kind of sucks and i almost sort of
wonder what it would have been like if
we'd used a third-party one that would
give us a 1080p version or something
like that but those are not as
consistent so just using straight up
youtube downloader and looking at the
file you know of course there's less
sharpness but it generally
basically resembles the original file
just a 720p version nothing too crazy
all right so i'm sitting in a room
different from the one you're in right
now and i'm recording both the sound of
my voice
and an image of myself all right so five
downloads in
it's getting softer here for sure
um and we're starting to see the effects
of not just losing detail but the
compression algorithms at work that are
trying to save detail and be efficient
so basically a video compression
algorithm we'll take a look at this
entire video it'll scan the whole thing
and essentially divide it into a bunch
of smaller blocks or groups of pixels
then it'll look through the video frame
by frame one by one by one and if a
certain block of pixels remains the same
through multiple frames it'll know that
it doesn't have to change much it can
keep that original frame through and
save some space this whole process is
called block motion estimation it's very
common with video compression and i'll
link a really good video below that
explains it super well it's only got a
couple thousand views but i think it
does the best job but basically the way
we notice this is certain parts of the
video that don't move like the
background for example they will stay
fine but the parts of the video that do
move like me will start to break down a
little bit
[Music]
all right so i'm sitting in a room
different from the one you're in right
now and i'm recording both the sound of
my voice
and an image of myself so here we go now
we're getting some more
dramatic compression it's super soft
overall of course my face the details in
it the skin is just super soft but again
the background which was already soft
isn't losing much detail at all in fact
it kind of looks the same as the
beginning because it isn't moving from
frame to frame they're just keeping
those old pixels until my arm passes
over in front of it or something then
you can kind of see it reset for a
couple frames also by now you've
probably noticed the audio
is a bit different turns out youtube
sort of shifts the audio or cuts back
the audio by about two frames with every
download and upload which isn't really
enough to notice at first but now it's
adding up for us to be able to see that
difference
[Music]
all right so i'm sitting in a room
different from the one you're in right
now and i'm recording both the sound of
my voice
and an image of myself okay so we're now
we're 20 downloads and 20 uploads in and
we've gotten to the point where you can
you can kind of start to see the blocks
or like the bigger chunks of pixels that
the compression algorithm is sort of
holding together it's kind of like a
math problem like if you just start
rounding
15 555 which is a pretty precise
measurement if you start rounding that
digit by digit over and over and over
again eventually you just get
20 000
which
does that make sense but what's funny is
you still notice there are still moments
when like i also pause
i'll stop moving for a couple of frames
and it'll also sharpen up again like
that right there at 27 seconds for a
second there there were consecutive
frames that i didn't really change too
much and so it duplicated the pixels and
it looked clear for a second
and then i move again and it goes right
back into chaos
[Music]
all right so i'm sitting in a room
different from the one you're in right
now and i'm recording both the sound of
my voice
and an image of myself okay so the audio
shift continues this time the audio
didn't start for a full two seconds two
and a half seconds into the video
and the first instance of what i'll call
brutal blockiness is also what's
happening it's grouping like blocks of
blocks so like bigger sections of pixels
because they're sort of close enough in
color that they might as well be the
same color from frame to frame and also
my skin tone is shifting from brown to
more magenta too if you've noticed that
and the pauses where i stop moving for a
second are even more dramatic like the
whole video frame kind of resets so i'll
wave my hand in front of the background
in front of the cheerios for a second
and it kind of smears magenta all over
it but when it gets back to a couple
still frames it all snaps back and the
smears disappear it's fascinating
[Music]
all right so i'm sitting in a room
different from the one you're in right
now it kind of just looks like now like
a struggling graphics card like like
someone turned rtx off the audio takes
four seconds this time to come in and
you can now actually kind of hear a
little bit of the audio compression
start to take effect it's not nearly as
drastic as the video but it kind of
sounds like um like behind
a thin cloth a little little muffled but
not too bad oh and my waving arms now
are leaving disappearing faint magenta
trails on my shirt and on the wall
behind me
all right so i'm sitting in a room
different from the one you're in right
now and i'm recording both the sound of
my voice
and an image of myself it's kind of
funny the first frame of this one looks
like it's gonna be okay
and then it all just goes to chaos now i
really look like the faceless cartoon
avatar that i used to have on here uh
the details in my skin not only has a
sharpness gone but like my eyes nose and
mouth are like almost completely gone
too and the magenta trails are getting
even more magenta they're closer to pink
oh and the sound too it doesn't even
sound necessarily that much worse but
it's shifted so far now that the entire
last sentence of the video was cut off
until all the original characteristics
of my voice
and my image
are destroyed and the pauses are so
dramatic now that when it finds
consecutive frames that haven't been
destroyed yet like right now it's still
around 26 seconds when i go from the
faceless character to a human and then
slowly descends back into a caricature
again it's really simplifying the colors
here with all the larger blocks of all
the rounding going on the background
though
honestly
still fine
[Music]
all right so i'm sitting in a room
different from the one you're in right
now and i'm recording both the sound of
my voice
and an image of myself
and i'm going to upload it to youtube
all right uh welcome to my personal hell
i don't think it can get much worse
than this facial features all the
structure all the contrast all the
detail all that is gone it's basically
turned into pink blocks and then
the best part now is just like how
pristine the background still kind of is
it's very similar to the original upload
like even though my actual caricature
has turned into a pink
blobbering blob whatever those those
paintings out of focus behind me kind of
look very similar to what they first
look like when i first downloaded it
[Music]
okay so this grand finale it's got it
all it's part art
part chaos
parts of it are completely
unintelligible like you can barely tell
it's like just a human being that's all
you really know
about what you're watching and then the
blocks are even bigger look at my
hairline like it looks like if you turn
the graphics all the way down as low as
they could possibly get
then you might end up with that sort of
level of minecraft quality and the audio
is completely gone so it slid from
slightly time delayed to a little bit
off to halfway through the video to
sliding completely out the other side so
it's completely empty there's no audio
in the thousandth upload turns out the
800th video is about the last time you
can hear me say anything
compressed over 800 times all right so
i'm sitting in a room yeah i bet if we
did another thousand downloads it would
look
kind of similar to the 1000th one also i
love that it still triggers the hd badge
because it is
technically still the 720p file but now
that this is done you can see any or all
of the thousand uploads on the channel
linked below so you can see the
auto-generated thumbnails get
progressively worse more nightmarish
over time and i'll basically toss in all
the important links below to milestone
videos so you can check them out for
yourself all right so i'm sitting in a
room different from the one you're in
right now and i'm recording both the
sound of my voice
and an image of myself
and i'm going to upload it to youtube
rip it from youtube
and then upload it again and download
and upload again and again and again
until all the original characteristics
of my voice
and my images
so
what have we learned
from doing all this well number one i
will say i think i have more respect for
youtube's processing and all their
compression than i did before
i obviously still think it looks much
better on my computer than on youtube
but it looks much better than the 2010
version i can say that for sure but then
number two the audio held up pretty well
aside from the whole shifting issue so
the actual quality was pretty decent it
got a little muffled but it didn't turn
into a puddle which is i say that
because in the original back in 2010
with that webcam video um have a look
this is his 1000th video
that is hilarious so i found this all
fascinating was it a gigantic waste of
time
no uh i think someone had to do it so
either way that's been it i'm happy to
finally share this with you after our
weeks and weeks of uploading and
downloading and uh shout out to the
original which was an audio experiment
so i'll link the info to that below as
well with all the rest of the stuff
it'll all be below the like button if
you want to check it out and of course
feel free to share this video with
anyone who might be interested in a high
quality super scientific analysis of
youtube processing
in 2019
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace